in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadeon, from Aeth, on which we commemorate our righteous father
Arseneus, the Great.
The illustrious Saint Arseneus was born into a Roman noble family at the beginning of
the 4th century.
Possessed of a keen intellect, he completed the whole cycle of secular studies, but as soon
as he was ordained Deacon, decided to apply himself solely to sacred learning.
He acquired such a reputation in the capital that when Theodosius the Great, Emperor of
the East, asked Grayson, Emperor of the West, to find a teacher for his sons Arcadius and
Onorius, he sent him Arseneus.
Despite of the honors of the court and the respect that Theodosius gave him, considering him
as a spiritual father, Arseneus, then aged 40, did not allow himself to be overcome by
such false attractions and desired to consecrate himself to God.
One night when he was begging God to show him the way to obtain salvation, he heard a heavenly
voice saying to him, Arseneus, flee the company of men.
And you will be saved.
Without further delay, he left the palace and went to the port where he found a ship that
took him to Alexandria.
He was immediately concerted as a monk in one of the numerous monasteries that surrounded
the Egyptian capital.
Although he had worn precious garments at the court, he now wore the most common of clothes,
which made him unrecognizable.
Following the vain knowledge of the world, he put himself in the school of the unlettered
Egyptian anchorites, whom he did not hesitate to question about all his thoughts.
After some time, when he once again begged God to show him how to be saved, the same voice
said, Arseneus, flee, be silent and remain in quietness, Hesikia.
These are the roots of perfection.
He therefore went to the celebrated monastic center of skitties, journeyed into the desert
and fixed his cell at more than 32 miles from the church.
He rarely left it, and for forty years spent all his time alone, before God alone, valiantly
resisting the suggestions of the demons who would recall to him his past life.
Each day he would question himself, Arseneus, why did you leave the world, and would ask
God the grace to begin?
Like the other hermits, Arseneus would spend his days plating palm fronds while reciting
verses of the Psalms.
He never changed the water in which the leaves were soaked, and patiently accepted the nauseous
odor that emanated from it.
In exchange, he used to say, for the perfumes and spices that he had used in the world.
His cell was devoid of all comfort, and he did not even possess a lamp, a basket of leaves
suffice him for food for a whole year.
He showed no repulsion for God's creation, however, and when the harvesting season arrived,
he would arrange for all sorts of fruits to be brought to him and tasted each just once.
He consecrated the entire night to prayer without sleeping at all, and in the early morning,
bowing to nature's demands, he would say, come here wicked slave, and then would take a
little sleep.
He used to say that an hour's sleep was sufficient for a monk if he were a true warrior.
On Saturday evening, this heavenly man began his vigil by turning his back to the setting
sun, and remained standing with his arms outstretched towards heaven until the sun illumined his face
again.
When visitors came to his cell to listen to his teaching, Saint Arsenius would refuse
to welcome them, even when they were the most highly placed.
To Theophilus Archbishop of Alexandria, who desired to visit him, he replied, if you come,
I shall open the door to you, but if I open it to you, I shall open it to everyone, then
I shall no longer remain here.
When they asked him why he thus fled human society, he would reply, God knows that I love you,
but I cannot live both with God and with men.
The myriads of celestial powers have a single will, while men have many wills.
I cannot therefore abandon God to be with men.
Prolonged retreat, silence, vigilance, and the guarding of the thoughts made a permanent
spring of tears flow from his eyes so that when Arsenius was seated for his manual work,
he always had a napkin resting on his chest to collect the tears which flowed without effort
and so abundantly that his eyelashes had fallen out.
This flow of tears had not only washed his soul of all the impurities of the passions but
had also transfigured his body, giving him the appearance of an angel.
His hair was completely white and his long beard descended to his belt.
One day a brother came to his cell and discreetly looked inside before knocking.
He saw the elder totally become fire, transfigured by the light of grace.
When from time to time St. Arsenius would go to the church of sketties for the synaxes,
he would place himself behind a pillar so that no one would see his face, and it was with
difficulty that the brethren were able to persuade him to reply to their questions.
He remained for about forty years in the desert of sketties.
When the barbarians assaulted the monks in 407, he passed by them without being seen.
But finally, after the second devastation of this renowned monastic center, he was forced
to take refuge on Mount Tro, Torah near Cairo, where he remained for ten years.
After his stay of three years in Canope, he returned to Tro, where he gave his soul into
God's hands at the age of 95, in the year 449.
When he was on the point of death, St. Arsenius ordered his disciples to abandon his body
in the mountain and said to them, I have often repented of having spoken but never of
having kept silent.
As the brethren saw him troubled, and in tears they asked him if he too, after having
attained to such a degree of impassibility, was still afraid.
He replied, in truth, the fear that I now have has accompanied me since the moment I became
among.
Then he delivered his soul to God.
Among other memorable sentences, St. Arsenius would say to his disciples, in so far as you
are able, make an effort to see that your interior occupation is pleasing to God, and you will
thus be able to conquer the exterior passions.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.